في أي نوع من قبعة الكروشيه الجميلة
عرض تحلق وجه نوبريك الكوكب
دعنا نقول علي جبابرة الروح حارس
فريق العقل في إقامة كاملة وأنا بحاجة إليك
مثل اللعبة التي تحبها
مع يديه مع التفاح هو هذا الحب
بنفسك تجعلها تعمل بالطريقة التي تريدها
من صعود الهاتف لساعات
ثاني حلم ريسلي العظيم ونظافة
لقد استخدمت هذا فقط في محاولة للدخول معي
بدوره الخاص بك التحول من البرامج الأخرى
مهندس في فريدي 1 خمس سنوات نحن
يجب أن تعاني مع الصحة تأكد من ذلك
هو نظيف وواضح اتصل بك سيدي
قلت لك خارج الصف
والكيلومترات هي سوبر ميغيل ألفينا
خاص أن هذا الشخص أعلن للتو أنه هذا
لا يجب أن يحدث في الطبخ
أخرجها وجدتها هنا أم أنك جمعتها من هناك
هل تقول أن الأشعة صنعت
يدويًا أنها مجرد كذبة
المضي قدما والحصول على موقع selfie و